in the episode river world of the comedy
Red Dwarf yes I'm sorry I missed that
episode let's go well it's season 6
episode 5 he writes thanks Brendon you
just wasted our lives uh one of the
characters goes from through a wormhole
in an escape pod that is accelerating
away from the other characters ship into
a wormhole to a planet that he would
land on they mentioned time dilation
effects of wormholes and the first one
through the wormhole had to wait 557
years before the rest of them caught up
to rescue to rescue him with that how
true would phenomena be hug true
phenomena be if the wormhole travel was
real yeah really yeah so a wormhole lets
allows you to go to another part of the
galaxy quickly much faster than a beam
of light would take you there by the way
if you can travel through wormholes it
allows backwards through time travel
that's how you would do it so that just
an FYI on that if you can travel you're
effectively travelling faster than light
and that allow certain trajectories
through the fabric of space and time
we're using sliders is pretty real if
they can manage the wormhole part so so
the point there is the wormholes if
you're accelerating through the wormhole
and you're moving fast you would not
aged very much at all you come out the
other side
everyone else is aging a long time right
but if someone else comes to a wormhole
right after you know you don't wait 500
years for them no no they'd just be
right there so yeah just configure both
using the same thing so it'd be about a
minute you know whatever whatever and
and the wormhole could be arbitrarily
short time for you right depending on
how warp the space is or how tight the
whole is between one section of the
galaxy in the net wait in fact this
thing that he's describing he should
have just said in the first reboot of
Star Trek there was a wormhole
you don't need to go into season six
episode five of red dwarf this is
literally the plot of your first Star
Trek to have a coverage of our wormholes
you don't need to be that specific in
your science fiction are you making a
much broader I mean anyway so that it's
the same thing about the Star Trek
you wouldn't yeah so so the point is if
you're all going in together or
immediately after one another yeah
you're good to go 15 minutes apart yeah
yeah yeah don't worry about it nice yeah
all right
[Music]